ich habe hier gesehen
wurde ihr direkt auf einer viel
befahrenen
ukrainischen käfer strafte die
polizisten und die armee ist noch
wahnsinnig nervös hier an der position
wir wurden gerade mit angezogener war
fragen gehalt man hat warnt davor dass
hier ein weiterer angriff passieren
könnte die russische armee in das
gebäude hier eines der größten
hochhäuser in tier attackiert und wie
die menschen thomas hat das natürlich
auch etwas symbolisches es ist als erste
wirkliche riesen hochhaus das hier
getroffen wurde wir recherchieren
gesprächen mit den menschen und
versuchen herauszubekommen ob es und wie
viele zivile opfer gegeben hat bei
ähnlichen angriffen aber bei sehr viel
kleinerem ausmass in den vergangenen
tagen dass die menschen im bunker waren
andere hoffen dass das aber wo wir
wollen dich nicht allzu lange aufhalten
ist es lebensgefährlich in diesem moment
auf den straßen zu sein im hintergrund
hat man gesehen dass einige menschen
dort unterwegs sind sind das einfach
zivilisten oder ist das militär kannst
du das irgendwie einsetzen ständig immer
ich hier einmal mit wir sehen dort
wir sind
mitten in eine kleine
natürlich von polizei und armee
und wenn wir uns hier umschauen thomas
dann muss man sagen ist das tatsächlich
ein horrorszenario
wenn wir die nächsten stunden oder tage
betrachten wenn weitere russische
raketen ihr auch die viele häuser fallen
sollten dann könnte ist eine hohe anzahl
von opfern ergeben ich muss sagen hier
um uns herum sind erstaunlich viele
zivilisten teilweise natürlich auch
journalisten lokale und internationale
journalisten über das berichten was ihr
in den straßen passiert nur was mich
verwundert hat war die maximale
nervosität die wir gerade hier bei der
armee noch erlebt haben dort bei dieser
einschlag ja schon ein bisschen her es
ist schon ein bisschen her dass das
ganze passiert ist und da ist durch
große große nervosität was das gesagt
man rechnet hier natürlich mit weiteren
angriffen dennoch ist es so thomas dass
diese angriffe meistens in der nacht
passieren also dann eines dunkel wird
und das ist auch das wofür man jetzt
ausgehen muss dass sich die russischen
einheiten wieder neu formieren wir
wissen dass es nachschub gebührt die
russischen soldaten es sollen auch
tschetschenische kämpfer unterwegs sein
und das ist das was im moment hier
passiert wir zeigen noch einmal die
straße die hieraus ein bisschen zu
nehmen da sind wir busse am straßenrand
busse fahren natürlich lenkt nicht mehr
genauso keine metro keine tram erfährt
in tier und jetzt
stand geworden schutzschilde wir sehen
hier auf dieser seite die trümmer auf
der straße von diesem angriff auf das
hochhaus etwas weiter dort wo jetzt ein
polizeiwagen fährt wir geben einfach mal
ein stück weiter noch in die richtung
las vegas show what is really hat ihn
gesehen wir straßensperren und wir sehen
überall bewaffnete menschen bewaffnete
polizisten
nervöses militär und wenn wir hier
weiter gehen und hier sehen wir gerade
wie ein mann abgeführt wird wir wissen
nicht genau was passiert ist hier wird
von der ukrainischen polizei gerade ein
zwei männern abgeführt wir wissen nicht
genau ob das im zusammenhang steht hier
möglicherweise mit dem angriff auf das
wohnhaus ist werden wir versuchen
rauszubekommen thomas paul und was für
eine kontraste durch chris dort blauer
himmel herrlichstes wetter in kiew in
der ukraine und die sonne hinter einem
haus das bombardiert wurde das zerstört
ist aus heiterem himmel sozusagen aus
heiterem himmel genau wir sehen dort und
eine copy play ist eine cosi bar zu
nennen sie das und jo gernoth lux upside
down hier
bin hier das hochhaus das angegriffen
wurde und hier die gesamten splitter der
schutz dieses angriffs nacht das ist ein
an thomas der kiew geschockt hat heute
morgen politiker am reagiert der
ukrainische aussenminister hat das als
beispiel genannt für einen angriff
online putin eben auch gegen zivilisten
an das ist eine lüge sei dass da nur
militär angegriffen wird sondern wie wir
hier sehen sehr wohl auch zivilisten
weil du hast dich jetzt also von seinem
eigentlichen standort außer durch die
stadt bewegen können die ukrainische
regierung sagt die lage in kiew sei
unter kontrolle die russischen angreifer
versuchen möglichst große zahlen von
militärtechnik und streitkräften in die
stadt zu bringen
russische saboteure seien aktiv gegen
die ukrainische sicherheitskräfte aber
erfolgreich durchbringen ist das dein
gefühl im moment auch die lage ist kiew
ist noch unter kontrolle
also ein schwieriges hier kein sprint
normalität oder irgendeiner und rolling
stone als als wir hier hingefahren und
bei dem bewahren den minuten haben wir
auf der straße bei explodierte wagen
gesehen eine polizei und ein militär das
nervös und schnell über die straftaten
kann hier an diesem ort die absolut
positiv aus das was hier passiert ist
bedeutet für viele menschen das wird
möglicherweise in den nächsten stunden
in den wagen auch ihre angeknüpft werden
könnten also etwas wie eine cosi bahrain
was das den ist auch unten ist ein
telefonshop und das sind einen typischen
sowjetischen gebäude wir gehen
vielleicht noch mal ein ganz kleines
stück weiter hier den dachten wir auch
die einschläge nicht obenan dabei auch
unten hier an diesem haus und wir
versuchen weiterhin herauszubekommen was
dort genau passiert ist beziehungsweise
ob es menschen gegeben hat die da zu
schaden gekommen
paul ronzheimer
vielen dank paul da sehen wir dich wir
es ist gefährlich auf den straßen
unterwegs zu sein bringt du dich bitte
jetzt auch wieder in sicherheit
danke für den moment